[music playing]
NARRATOR: We humans
are hardwired
to choose mates with the
highest possible value.
[dings]
Our bio-mall shoppers
are all wearing
a number between one and six.
Even though they can't
see their own numbers,
Rebel and the others will
pair off and try to make
the highest total number.
Science says that similar
numbers will automatically
pair off with one another--
sixes with sixes, threes
with threes, and so on.
[applause]
OK.
So I'm going to put this--
This is different, because
I normally do online shopping.
[laughter]
So.
Going to put
that on your head.
- OK.
- All right.
That's OK?
OK.
So you put a
number on my head.
I've put a number
on your head.
Now I'd like to emphasize that
these numbers were randomly
assigned, so don't get bummed
out or impressed with yourself
when you find out that
you're a one or a six.
REBEL WILSON: Yeah.
HOST: All right?
When I say go--
So [inaudible], no one's a 10?
[laughter]
You're a 10, Rebs.
Yeah, yeah, in my heart.
Yeah, thanks.
But in this game--
[applause]
So you've got 30 seconds.
[drum tapping]
Go.
OK.
So I'm going to
look around, see--
HOST: OK.
REBEL WILSON: --who's got--
OK.
HOST: So try to make the
highest total possible.
MAN: [inaudible] go past.
REBEL WILSON: Going to go--
HOST: [laughs]
REBEL WILSON: I've got my one.
OK, I'm going to choose you.
HOST: And we're at-- we got 15.
You got 15 seconds.
Line up behind here.
Line up right here.
Having headband issues.
And that's good.
Stop right there.
All right.
Got a two and a
three together here.
So you guys came up with a
five out of a possible 12.
That's not bad.
Here we got a four and a five.
That's a nine.
Now you took him.
You couldn't find a five?
- Yeah.
It was getting down
to the last minute,
and you just had to grab the
highest number that was left.
[laughter]
No, it's OK.
It's just an exercise.
That's the way it works
in the market, folks.
[laughter]
So a two and a three.
Were you guys going
for something bigger?
What was happening?
- I was going for bigger.
And then people were,
like, looking at me going,
no, thank you.
- OK.
Oh, that's-- I'm so sorry.
That's not-- well, you guys,
five is better, if I may,
just mathematically
speaking, than a two.
- I was looking for the sixes--
- The last [inaudible]
--and nobody
was looking at me.
HOST: Nobody was looking at you?
- No.
They weren't even giving
you the time of day?
At all.
Oh, man.
[whistles] I'm glad I'm married.
[laughter]
This is-- this dating
stuff is tough.
[applause]
So now Rebel--
Yeah.
--this gentleman
here is a six.
You found a six.
I was decisive too.
I saw that six, went for it.
Yeah.
Just--
Locked him down.
- Locked him down.
- Yeah.
She got me.
She grabbed you pretty quick.
Mhm.
She was just like this,
and she went enough,
and then bam, right,
just pulled in there.
Yeah, yeah.
Do you know what
number you are?
One?
Rebel, a one?
You're a six.
Oh.
You are definitely a six.
All right.
So we found-- yeah.
I got a feeling
you would have taken
her even if she wasn't a six,
if she was lower than a six.
With Rebel, I'm a
winner either way.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
That's very sweet.
Aw.
That is lovely.
[applause]
They ended up with who they
were supposed to end up,
more or less, from an
evolutionary standpoint.
The sixes are with
the other sixes.
The ones are with
the other ones.
[music playing]
NARRATOR: This experiment
demonstrates the phenomenon
known as homogamy.
Some scientists think it
happens because we have
an instinctual preference for
an equally desirable partner,
while others believe we
calculate our own mate
value through
interactions with others
and then settle for the best
mate we think we can get.
[music playing]